Our reading today will be from the letter of Paul to the Ephesians chapter 1 verse 3 through 14.
Blessed be the God and Father of our Lord Jesus Christ, who has blessed us in Christ
with every spiritual blessing in the heavenly places, even as he chose us in him before the
foundation of the world, that we should be holy and blameless before him in love.
He predestined us for adoption to himself as sons through Jesus Christ according to the purpose
of his will, to the praise of his glorious grace with which he has blessed us and the beloved.
In him we have redemption through his blood, forgiveness of our trespasses according to
the riches of his grace which he lavished upon us in all wisdom and insight, making known to
us the mystery of his will according to his purpose which he set forth in Christ.
As a plan for the fullness of time to unite all things in him, things in heaven and things on earth.
In him we have obtained an inheritance, having been predestined according to the purpose of him
who works all things according to the counsel of his will so that we who were first to hope
in Christ might be to the praise of his glory. In him you also, when you heard the word of truth,
the gospel of your salvation and believed in him were sealed with the promised Holy Spirit,
who is the guarantee of our inheritance until we acquire possession of it
to the praise of his glory. This is the word of the Lord.
Thank you, Nick. Well, let's have Ephesians chapter one open together as we continue to study this
book and hear what the Lord has to say to us. Before we get into the verses themselves, I'll
remind it as I opened it this week of a story about an Argentinian maid and she grew up never
knowing her father, who he was. And she had heard some rumors that it could have been a man that she
had heard of and he was an incredibly wealthy man and he had died several years before and he
had died without being married and without having any children. But through DNA testing,
she then discovered that he was in fact her father. And because he was her father,
she was now recognized as the rightful heiress to 40 million dollars that he had left behind. So
needless to say, her life was changed dramatically. I think there was like a nine-year court case that
then followed to actually get ahold of this inheritance that was hers, but it eventually
came her way. So in discovering more about her identity, she then discovered riches that
she never knew that she had. Well, last week as we looked at Ephesians chapter one, we saw
our identity as being in Christ. And this week we're going to see the riches that come with that
identity that is ours in Christ, right? So upon discovering this identity, we discover riches
that are ours in him. So if you've been united to Jesus by faith and there is a goldmine,
if you will, of blessings that belong to you in him ready for you to discover and explore. And so
you see this right from the beginning of our text this morning. So Ephesians chapter one, verse three
says, blessed be the God and Father of our Lord Jesus Christ, who has blessed us in Christ with
every spiritual blessing in the heavenly places. So in Christ we have been blessed. Now recognize
that blessed is one of those words that kind of has multiple meanings depending on where
you're at in the world, especially here in the south. So if somebody says to you, bless your heart,
what do they mean exactly? The answer is it totally depends on the context. It could mean I'm
expressing some sincere sympathy here, or it could mean I'm looking on you with sheer contempt
right now, but trying to say it in a nice way. But what does Paul mean when he talks about
these blessings here? Well, first of all he talks about blessing God. So to bless God is to praise God.
The word here is actually the word that we get our word eulogy from, right? So that kind of
speech where you're extolling somebody's good qualities, right? That comes from that word
blessed here. So this is what Paul is doing. He is praising God. So it isn't that God has
some need that we can help to supply, like he needs to be blessed by us. So what does God
want from us? He wants praise because he is the one who's provided all that we need. And that's
really what this whole section is. It's a kind of explosion of praise. Like I almost think of it as a,
you can imagine like a space shuttle, like just like taking off and you're strapped in and Paul's
taking us on this journey like through the atmosphere into heaven itself. And it's kind
of broken up for us in English in like different sentences. But in the original Greek, this
is one long sentence, this entire section. It's 202 words where Paul is just rapid fire,
worshiping God, and he just cannot stop. It's like this with this run on sentence of praise.
So why is he praising him? Why should we praise God? Why should we bless him? Because God has
blessed us. So we bless him because he first blessed us. And there's specific kind of
blessings that Paul is praising God for here. And they're not the kinds of blessings that you might
see, I don't know, like on an Instagram post with the hashtag blessed beside it. They are
spiritual blessings. They're blessings that we cannot see with our eye. In case there's any
doubt as to what kind of blessings he's referring to, he goes on to refer to them as heavenly
blessings. They're in heavenly places. So by that, we're not saying that God doesn't bless
us materially. That is true. Every good gift comes from him. All the good that we enjoy comes
ultimately from our Creator. And that's true of Christians and non-Christians alike.
But those are not the kinds of blessings that he's referring to here. He's referring to
a kind of blessing that is only true for those who are in Christ. So there's a unique kind
of blessing here, these spiritual blessings. But they're also, they're plentiful blessings.
So he's praising God for how abundantly we have been blessed in Christ. We haven't just been blessed
with spiritual blessings. We've been blessed with every spiritual blessing in the heavenly places.
Since almost like a, well, it's not like this. It's the opposite. You can imagine like a flight
you get on and what's the first thing you do when you get on a flight or at least the first
thing that I do is I walk past everybody who's in first class and I go into economy. So there's
the kind of different sections that are there and kind of a different experience is going to be
had by different people there. Well, if we are in Christ, there isn't the kind of first class and
then economy. Like we're all in Christ together and all of these blessings belong to every believer
who belongs to Christ. So this begs the question then, what are these blessings,
these spiritual abundant blessings that every believer can enjoy and praise God for? Well,
they're presented to us chronologically here moving from past to present to future. And each one of them
probably needs a full sermon, a full disclosure. I've preached through the book of Ephesians
before in the past, and I probably took five or six weeks to go through this section. So this
feels like we're going to hit it like Paul hits it here with kind of rapid fire. So what are
the blessings? First of all, I want us to see the blessing of election. Okay, so he's blessed
us with these spiritual blessings. Verse four, even as he chose us in him before the foundation of the
world. Verse five, he predestined us for adoption to himself as sons. So in Christ, we can praise God
for the blessing of our election for the fact that we were chosen in Christ before the foundation
of the world. We can praise God for predestination. And I must say the church plant was great while it
lasted. Let me just, elephant in the room, let me just kind of point to him here. I realize that
election predestination being chosen is a controversial doctrine. And it's one that we can have
disagreements about. And I understand that. But it is a doctrine that is in Scripture. And so I
don't want us to shy away from anything that Scripture actually teaches us because it might
scare us or it runs the risk of disagreements. Let me just say this as a kind of little sidebar
here. As we come to Scripture, it is more important to stick with revelation as opposed to running off
into speculation. So it's more important to stick with what is revealed rather than our
curiosity about that going beyond what Scripture actually teaches. So by all means, let's
think these things through. But our foundation must be what God has told us rather than our ability to
make complete sense of the thing, whatever it is. And sometimes that means holding two truths in
tension. That doesn't mean that they are contradictory. It doesn't mean that they are
illogical. It just means that our understanding is limited. God's ways are higher than our
ways. His thoughts are higher than our thoughts. But that being said, you know, if you want to
talk about this further, let's talk about it. I'm more than happy to discuss this. So what does
the text teach us here about our election? Well, if you're in Christ, you can praise God
because He chose you before the foundation of the world. So He chose us and Him before the
foundation of the world. So we might say, well, wait, hang on a second. Did we choose God or
did He choose us? Like, I can remember back when I chose Him. Well, the answer to the
question of did we choose God or did He choose us is yes. They're both true. I hope there was
a point in time that you chose to repent of your sin and put your faith in Christ. And it's when
that happens that we are united to Christ. But at the same time, this is also true. Before you
ever came on the scene, before the world itself was created, God looked upon you and He chose
you if your faith is in Christ. So He chose you before you chose Him.
And His choosing is the one that brings about our holiness. So last week, we saw that,
what does it call us in verse 1? We call it saints, right? So we saw that part of our
identity in Christ is that we are saints. We are God's holy people. Well, how did that come
about? How did our holiness come about? It comes about through Christ who forgives our sins
and gives us His righteousness. But before that ever happened in our experience and even
before Jesus ever came into this world before the foundation of the world, God chose us to be His
holy people. And notice it isn't our holiness that drew God to us. We were sinners just like
everybody else. God doesn't look at us and say, well, wow, they are holy. They're getting it
right. And so I'm going to choose them. No, it is God's choosing that brings about our holiness. He
chose us that we should be holy and blameless before Him. Right? So His choosing is the cause.
Our holiness is the effect. And how does He bring His chosen, His elect to faith in Christ?
Well, we'll have to skip down to verse 13, right? So you've got the truth of verse four. We are chosen
in Him, but that does not negate the truth of verse 13. That those are in Him are in Him
because they heard the preaching of the Word. They heard the preaching of the gospel
and they believed in Christ. So what should we do? We should preach the gospel to everyone.
We should call on everyone to believe in Christ and to receive Him. And then when that happens,
when people believe in Christ, we should give God all the glory because their salvation,
our salvation is owing entirely to His grace. There are many examples in Scripture where these
two things are drawn together. But one of them is in the book of Acts in chapter 13.
Great example here. Paul is preaching the gospel in Antioch. He's preaching now primarily to a Gentile
audience that is there. He's preaching to anyone who will listen. He's casting the net wide.
And many of them then believe, but listen to how Luke describes what happened when people believed.
Acts chapter 13 and verse 48. It says, And when the Gentiles heard this, they heard the gospel,
they began rejoicing and glorifying the Word of the Lord. And then as many as were appointed
to eternal life believed. You notice the order there. So they hear, they believe, and they rejoice.
Well, who are the people who rejoiced and believed? It was those who were appointed to
eternal life. Luke could have written it the other way around, but he puts it in that order
before the foundation of the world. And therefore they believe. So who is the gospel
preached to? Everyone, absolutely everyone who will believe the message and receive eternal life,
who will choose to repent and believe? Well, those who were chosen by God. It's been said before
this way, if heaven had a front door on one side, it would say, whosoever will may come.
And that is absolutely true. And then on the other side, when you look back at it,
it says chosen in him before the foundation of the world, right? So we come to Christ and we see
that this is about what he has done for us. So election here isn't presented to us once again
as a as a controversy to be avoided, but a blessing to be celebrated. Think of it. Before
we were ever born, God looked upon us in love. And he said, I'm going to make them my own.
They belong to me. Praise God. And that ties in with the next blessing. We might think, well,
what makes God's choice such a blessing? Well, because of the second blessing that's mentioned
here, and that's the blessing of adoption. It's such a blessing because he chooses us for adoption.
So let's read verse five. In love, he protested us for adoption to himself as sons through Jesus
Christ. So what is adoption? J.I. Packer said, our understanding of Christianity cannot be better
than our grasp of adoption. So this is something that's really important for us to get hold of here.
And there's lots that could be said. I'll just kind of summarize by saying adoption is the
wonderful truth that God sets his love upon us, welcomes us into his family, and gives us
all the rights and privileges of sons. So let me break that down a little bit. So
it is God setting his love upon us. So adoption is an act of love. So he talks about,
in love, he protested us for adoption to himself. So our adoption comes about because God loves us.
This is how John praises God in 1 John 3 and verse 1 for the same reason. He says,
behold what manner of love the Father has given to us that we should be called the children of God.
We're the children of God because of God's love for us as His children. So the choosing is a decision
of love. It isn't mere determination that's going on here, but delight. We're not just chosen to
be servants, but sons, right? So there's a love that is being shown to us here in Christ.
And it's true to say that God's love is universal, but it's also true and gloriously true that he has
a special love for his children. I mean, we all know this in our own kind of experience. Like,
I hope I could say like, I love people, and that that would be a true statement. Yeah,
I love people. But then also when I look at one of my children and I say, I love you,
there's some overlap there, but there's something different in what I'm communicating to my child.
There's a different depth of love that is there a greater depth. And if you are in Christ, it's because
God has looked upon you in love with the love of the Father for his children.
Okay, so God loves us. And so then he brings us into his family as his own, as his own
as his own children. We're not naturally children of God. We become children of God.
And this happens once again through receiving Christ. So John chapter one, verse 12 says,
but as many as received him to those he became the right or were given the right to become
a children of God, to those who believe on his name. So how can we know that we are God's
children? Well, have we received Christ? Have we believed on his name? See, he is the beloved son.
And if we are accepted as God's children, we are accepted in the beloved in him,
loved as God's very own. You see that in the beloved statement there at the end of verse six,
by the way. But if you're one of God's children, here's another blessing of adoption.
God gives you all the rights and privileges of a son. It isn't like Harry Potter. You know,
Harry Potter when he moved in with his aunt and uncle, he wasn't given the right of a son. He had
to live in the cupboard under the stairs. So he wasn't treated as a son. He was in the house,
but he was treated as less than. He wasn't given all the good that the other boy,
his cousin was given. That's not the case with God. He fully welcomes everyone whose faith is in
Christ. He welcomes them as his own children as sons. And let me just acknowledge that calling us
sons here in verse five may not sit well with our kind of modern sensibilities
that were adopted as sons specifically. It might feel regressive that it doesn't read as
sons and daughters here. A couple of things about that. One is there are lots of times in
scriptures where we are referred to as sons and daughters, where it's a kind of all-inclusive,
right? So they are both there. But there seems to be something more specific going on here. Why
were spoken of as sons? And it's not that Paul is putting women down here. It's actually that
he is lifting them up. What do I mean by that? Well, in the ancient world, sons, particularly
firstborn sons, were the ones who inherited the family wealth. And Paul is about to start talking
about our inheritance as Christians. He's talking about the riches that are ours in Christ.
And here we see that this status applies to everyone who is in Christ. So whether you're a man
or a woman, if you are in Christ, you are given this privileged status as a firstborn son, right?
So you see, we are all included, every child of God. So the blessing of adoption, the God who
reigns over everything invites us to call him Father. He knows us. He loves us. He welcomes
us as his child. So praise God for adoption. But a good question to ask at this point is,
yes, but what about our sin? Like if we know that God is holy, our sin would cause us to shy away
from running to him as our Father. Let's say, find out what we have done, what we are really like,
which is why we have this next blessing. That's the blessing of thirdly redemption.
So let's read verse seven together. In him, in Christ, we have redemption through his blood,
the forgiveness of our trespasses according to the riches of his grace. So we have been redeemed.
We've received the blessing of redemption if we are in Christ. So what does that mean? Well, the
word redeemed or redemption is essentially liberating someone upon the payment of a ransom.
Right? So liberating somebody because their ransom has been paid, a price has been paid
for them. And there's an old story that illustrates this. Well, you may have heard this. I know I've
heard it a number of times growing up, but this is this is so helpful. The story about a boy
who made he and his family lived by the sea and he and his father really enjoyed going to the sea
together. And what they did one day is they decided they were going to build a boat together.
And so they built this boat and they took it out to the sea for it to sail and they had
just an amazing time and that became their kind of routine together. They would go out to sail this
boat together, this toy boat. But one day this gust of wind came and it swept the boat away
and they couldn't get out to the boat and they just, you know, it was it was no more
as far as they were concerned. But then a few weeks later that same boy was walking down
the street and he came to a pawn shop and there in the window of the pawn shop was his boat.
And so he went into the pawn shop and he spoke to the owner and he said,
that's my boat in the window. Can I have my boat in the pawn shop owner? He said, well,
a sailor came in the other day and he sold me this boat. He said, I paid good money for that
boat. He said, so that the price stands. So if you if you want the boat, you can pay for
it, but I'm not just going to give it to you. And so the boy then left a bit sad, but then
he started to work and do everything that he could to get the money necessary to buy the boat.
And so he came finally to the pawn shop with money in hand, the boat's still there,
and he purchased his own boat. So he walks away with joy holding his boat and he says,
you're mine. You're twice mine. I made you and I bought you. Right? So that is what redemption is.
Right? God made us. We go away from him and our sin, but he purchases us and brings us back
to himself. Right? So purchase, liberating upon the payment of a price. But it's a recurring theme,
like right the way throughout scripture. So in terms of biblical illustration, you could look
at the Exodus in particular. And in the Exodus, you see the Israelites are enslaved in Egypt,
but God made them a promise in their slavery. Right? He had already chosen them for himself
and he says to them Exodus chapter six, verses six and seven, he says, I am the Lord.
And I will bring you out from under the burden of the Egyptians and I will deliver you from slavery to
them. And I will, here's the word redeem you with an outstretched arm and with great acts of
judgment. I will take you to be my people and I will be your God. So he gives them the promise
that he's going to deliver them from slavery and you see, then see how that unfolds. And then there's
God's pouring out his judgment on Egypt and there's this final act of judgment on their final night
there. But he makes this way for his people to escape judgment. And what is it? The sacrifice of a
lamb and the blood was put over the doorposts of the house. And so as they make their way out
of Egypt, they're making their way under the doorposts where this lamb has been sacrificed.
They have escaped judgment and instead been liberated. So all this is pointing forward to this
greater redemption that is to come through Christ. So what's the picture? Like in Egypt, we are
enslaved, enslaved to sin. This is true of our condition. It's true of the choices that we make.
I mean, if you have any wonder as to whether or not you are actually enslaved to sin,
just try to, I don't know, not sin for a week. It doesn't work out for a week. Maybe try to
not sin for a day and see how that works out for you. The fact is we all still fall into old habits
and old ways, even ones that we despise were not as free as we would like to think. If God is holy
and just and he is, then our sin deserves to be punished. Here's the wonderful news of redemption
that Jesus paid the price to set us free. He pays the price by dying in our place.
And on the cross, what does he say? It is finished, literally paid in full.
He was the sacrificial lamb whose blood was shed on our behalf that we might be set free. He made us
and he redeems us. So 1 Peter chapter one, verses 18 and 19 says that this, knowing that you were
ransomed from the futile ways inherited from your forefathers, not with perishable things such
as silver or gold, but with the precious blood of Christ, like that of a lamb without blemish or spot.
So we don't kind of sneak into God's family hoping that he doesn't find out what we are really like.
He already knows. And it isn't that he overlooks our sin. No, he does something far better.
He pays for it himself out of the lavish riches of his grace. He pays in full
through the shedding of the precious blood of Christ. It's through faith in Jesus that we can
know that we are forgiven and we can run straight into the loving arms of our Heavenly Father,
confidence that he will receive us. So praise God for redemption.
So let's look at the last blessing we can praise God for and that is our inheritance.
See redemption isn't just about what he's brought us out of. It's about what he is bringing us into.
And that is our inheritance. So where do we see that? In verse 11,
in him we have an obtained an inheritance having been predestined according to the purpose of him
who works all things according to the counsel of his will. So what is our inheritance? Well,
in the Old Testament, once again, go back to the Exodus when the people of God were redeemed from
Egypt, they were redeemed that they might be brought into the land of promise. It was their
inheritance that was waiting for them. So whatever they were facing in Egypt, they could,
they could hold on to the hope that they had an inheritance waiting for them in the promised land.
So Ephesians chapter six, verse eight, it's the same verse where God says,
I'm going to redeem you. And then after that in verse eight, he says, I will then bring you into
the land that I swore to give to Abraham to Isaac and to Jacob, I will give it to you
for your possession. I am the Lord. So when they were set free, when they were liberated,
when they were redeemed, they were now free to go and claim their inheritance. And as they went,
God's presence went with them every step of the way. So what is the inheritance that we have to
look forward to? We're going to look at this in more detail next week. But for the moment,
I want to see this, that God plans to redeem the whole of creation. And the inheritance
that we have to look forward to is a perfect life together with God in the new creation,
where everything that was wrong has finally been made right. Okay, so our inheritance is to be with
him one day in the perfect new creation where there's no more sin, no more sorrow, no more
suffering, no more death. How can we know that that is coming, that we will be there
in the new creation with him? On Thursday evening, we went to the Coleman Fair,
I don't know if anybody's been there before. And we went there. And so the kids were all looking
forward to going there. And we've paid the price of entry. And you can see all the rides there,
all the good that we're about to step into. And but before we're given a final access to it,
we're given a stamp on our hands. And that stamp served as a kind of seal showing that we were allowed
in that we were able to enjoy all of the festivities taking place, taking place inside.
What did it say? Get into you remember what it said? It said spin. It said spin. There we go.
And so we had this stamp on our hands. And so we've paid the stamp is there. We know
that some good is coming. So here we see that God has given us a seal, a stamp showing that we belong
to him. And that stamp, that seal is the entry of the guarantee of our entry into all that is to
come. What is this seal? What's the entry? It's that he has given us his holy spirit. So where
do we see that now? Verse 13, in him also when you heard the word of truth, the gospel of
your salvation and believed in him were sealed with the promised Holy Spirit, who was the guarantee of
our inheritance until we acquire possession of it to the praise of his glory. So what's it teaching us
here? It's teaching us that the presence of the Holy Spirit in our lives is how God marks us out as
his known. It's his presence in our lives that is the guarantee or the first installment of
all that is to come when we dwell with him together. How can we know that we will dwell with God
forever in the new creation because God dwells with us now by the presence of his spirit. His spirit
assures our hearts that we belong to Christ and that we will be with him forever. So you might
say, well, how do I know that I have the Holy Spirit? And I realized that people's different
church traditions kind of come into play when you think about that. You might think, is it like an
overwhelming sensation? Unless I have that overwhelming sensation, I can't know that I have the Holy
Spirit or maybe it's the gift of tongues. You know, when I'm speaking tongues, then I can know
that I have the gift of the Holy Spirit. But did you notice what Scripture says here about how
we can know that we have received the Holy Spirit? When does it happen? It happens when we
heard the word of truth, the gospel of your salvation and believed in him. It's when that happens,
we're told that we were sealed with the promised Holy Spirit. So it's upon belief in Christ that we
are then sealed with the promised Holy Spirit. So if you are in Christ, if your faith is in
him, know this, you have been given the very spirit of God. And it's the spirit of God
that assures your heart that you belong to Christ, that this gospel is true, and you will be brought
all the way to glory. He will see to that. And so you can confidently praise God even now
for your inheritance. So how should we respond to all these rich blessings that we have in Christ?
Well, three words. One is receive these blessings. If we receive it when we put our faith in
Christ, let me invite you this morning to put your faith in him. All of these riches are freely
offered to us in the gospel. So here's how we respond by holding out the empty hands of faith
and receiving what God has done for us in Christ. And if you've received them,
second word is remember them. Remember them. I don't know about you, but I can give
a lot of attention to the things that I feel that I lack. And sometimes they have my attention far more
than the abundant riches that are mine in Christ. We're all prone to forget. So maybe we should
speak the words of Psalm 103 to ourselves this week. Bless the Lord, O my soul and all that
it was that is within me. Bless his holy name. Bless the Lord, O my soul and forget not all
of his benefits. And as we remember what we've been given in Christ, there's a lot of joy there,
but it isn't just to cheer ourselves up. We remember them that we might praise the one who
is giving them to us. So receive, remember, and then resound the praises of the one who gave
them to you. Let's do that now as we pray and then sing together.
God, we want to praise you for blessing us with every spiritual blessing in Christ.
What you have done for us is far beyond our comprehension.
But Lord, we want to praise you for your grace and thank you for all that you have given us in
Jesus. Lord, according to your will, you have poured out the riches of your grace upon us.
Lord, we praise you for choosing us, for adopting us, for redeeming us, for giving us an inheritance.
So Lord, we praise you, Father, for all that you have given us. We want to praise
you, Son, for redeeming us by laying down your life for us. We want to praise you, Spirit,
for revealing these glorious truths to us. So God, by your grace, we pray that you'd help us
to receive them by faith and to live for your glory and to praise you. In Jesus' name, amen.